it's not definitive conclusive
information of what exactly happened the
rescue operation is lies it's currently
underway mouth waters in waters north of
Libya tell us about the rescue operation
well effectively the information that we
have is that 700 people would have been
on a boat that capsized that we are
trying to address and what's important
about this is that it highlights the
incredible dangers of this voyage that
people are taking that they are forced
to take right now these people are
victims of violence they are fleeing
they're running for their lives and
they're risking their lives to try to
find safe harbor and this vote is
capsized in that process what's
happening there at the moment we as you
say up to 700 migrants on board we
believe that some have been have managed
to be rescued I don't have any precise
information on figures we're getting
more information as the situation
unfolds I've given you all the
information that I have but just to
emphasize that these people are running
for their lives that's why they're
taking this incredible risk risking
everything to try to find safety how are
you made aware Andre of what happens how
did they contact you or how you made
aware of the situation there in the
Mediterranean Sea you are both receive
distress calls and then they respond to
them several other boats we believe also
in the area at the moment it has been
described Andre as the as the most
dangerous journey in the world at the
moment and yet so many thousands of
people are still willing to take it as
you were saying well this is precisely
the point is it's the most dangerous
journey in the world as described and
people are still doing it anyway in this
situation just highlights exactly how
dangerous that is they're literally
risking their lives because they have no
other choice if you can imagine what
kind of circumstances would drive you
and your family to make such a decision
to flee like this to risk life and limb
that's just how dire things are in the
world right now majority of the people
making these trips
are people who are fleeing from conflict
it's active and ongoing that's from
Afghanistan from Somalia from Syria from
Eric from other conditions and in
countries like Eritrea and it just
highlights the gravity of this situation
what's happened today